alors je fais un peu perdre de temps à
fabien olicard s'est passé quelque chose
pendant nos vacances il ya quelque chose
qui s'est pas fait
quelque chose
j'arrive à
saluer ce que vous souvenez des vidéos
que je sortais avec des impros du
spectacle en gros régulièrement sur
instagram c'est celui ci on vous attend
sur instagram je mets des moments du
spectacle qui sont des impros une fois
de temps en temps je m'étais dit ça
pourrait être intéressant de les mettre
sur youtube et on l'a fait la première
l'a vraiment car tonnelle vous avez bien
plus la deuxième aussi et nous sur cette
belle lancée on s'est dit faut pas
lâcher ça fait deux ans qu'il n'a pas eu
parce que ça prend énormément de temps
mais cinq pauline est arrivé au bureau
et pauline elle s'est tapé le décrochage
de plus de 20 mai spectacle
vous le savez peut-être pas mais je
mémorise plus de 30 à 40 prénom à chaque
spectacle est pour le faire j'utilise
des images mentales pour que ça
s'accroche rapidement ça donne ça
au prénom c'est adrien adrien moi je
t'imagine très grand blond tu vois très
pulpeuse tu vas adriana en fait
est plus une image à les bêtes dans ma
tête et mieux je le retiens vous avez
tout ce qui s'appelle adrien pour le
reste de votre vie des gens on
t'appelait adrian moi rappelle moi ton
prennent mille à moi en fait en
mnémotechnique je me dis allez en
première position parce que je les 1000
à dorine donc moi je pense aux poissons
dans les mots ok direct c'est quel est
ton prénom
clémentine ok bon je t'imagine vraiment
déguisé en clémentine c'est merveilleux
dans ma tête des votes entrer dans gm
théo de combien
est ton prénom
elisabeth elisabeth j'imagine vraiment
comme la reine d'angleterre là tu vois
elle ne fait jamais ça l'a
vraiment j'ai pas vu un un stade la
reine d'angleterre comme toi ton prénom
julian julian julian
alors moi les images mentales il faut
que je prenne la première qui me vient
dans ma tête est là pour moi c'est un
barman dans la forêt il sert des jus de
liane en liane comme ça
je vous ai dit c'est pas bien être là
dedans des prénoms
nelly hockey nelly moi je t'imagine
vraiment avec une grosse encyclopédie en
train de tourner les pages avec tomber
mais lis
ton prénom
oui c'est vrai qu'il t'a pas tout voir
sur terre ok moi je me dis tiens
pourquoi il est un bonnet parce que
jérémy un bonnet marques marques marques
je me dis que tu es en feu tu vois que
du sucre âme ses marques à l'envers j'ai
lu dans les deux sens dans ma tête tout
l'alphabet donc marc hockey
la partie suivante comment vous dire
c'est la partie de tuffé 160
représentations avec un spectacle études
il s'est passé tout ce qui pouvait se
passer veut dire le public ne peux plus
me surprendre eh bien c'est faux
est ce que tu peux tenir le micro pour
chasser ça c'est qu'il m'a dit c'était
charles ton prénom oui et alors on va le
faire avec toi pour te mettre mal à
l'aise évidemment et il tient le micro
pour charles clp alors charlatans attend
avant d'ouvrir
de quoi
charlatans roi
vous avez un coup d'avancé sur moi je ne
fais pas que des jeux de mots
volontaires ok j'étais avec qu'est ce
que j'ai dit d'ailleurs le pire truc
pour le mentalisme c'est quelqu'un qui
veut que ça marche c'est très compliqué
du goût donc quoique jouera contre ma
life pense à ta carte là par contre
pensez vraiment as 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
soit les dames brasse alors par contre
artix mes mouvements dont tu t'inquiètes
pas je fais un truc bizarre as 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 palettes en bois as j'ai
l'impression du québec
ça va venir
aulas sait pas quelle image vous êtes
fait mais moi c'était une fontaine à eau
rocher
moi je ne comprends pas ce qui se passe
dans la tête de ces gens là pourquoi ils
reprennent pis sans déconner trou ils
font ça
par des qui tu sors
tony dû dans un premier temps tu vas
parler bien fort en me disant toujours
la vérité quel est ton prénom tony
toujours la vérité qui allaitent on
présente ni tu
montes encombre pas de l'humour
le roi de pique le monsieur antonio
s'est montrée merci un peu mieux que les
territoires d'un cadeau pour moi
ok
oui
vous êtes des dindes ce soir dac
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
jérôme peut-être je prends les stylos
comme ça tu pourras mieux mélanger
vérification bien toutes les trois faces
en bas continuent de les mélanger un peu
et la station la gauche s'il te plaît
regarde je ferme les yeux comme ça n'est
pas de souci je te sens pas c'est
maintenant je sais pas où tu es
comme le dit je te sens passé j'ai
entendu quelqu'un dire titre c'est très
drôle
c'est bon ok on fait des intonations du
mensonge maintenant quoi qu'il arrive tu
me manques lé ton prénom jean pierre
y avait de la joie
et hisser le plus perturbant landreau
sait que d'habitude quand je demande le
prénom de quelqu'un un temps de
réflexion
et lui direct et jean-pierre
et et j'ai vu du vent dans les cheveux
de la lumière
ma vie j'ai voulu m'appeler jean-pierre
maintenant on va essayer de retrouver la
valeur de takhar ok tu vas dire toutes
les cartes de la son rang le plus vite
possible tu dis 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 etc
ces partis ni tu écoutes ont un autre à
quatre axes est une amie trois quarts
aux manettes
qu'est ce qu'on peut apprendre de ça
en vrai c'est toujours des moments très
cool parce que ça nourrit de spectacles
différemment et moi j'adore ça c'est de
la matière à faire de l'impro il n'y a
pas que le public d'ailleurs qui réagit
ou qui fait des choses parfois
étonnantes mais régisseur de spectacle
principalement diablo et gary dont on
travaille ensemble depuis 2008 et puis
sont rodés ça fait 200 fois qu'on fait
le spectacle là ensemble si on compte
avec les festivals et où l'eau qui peut
arriver ils peuvent plus rien oublié
sauf ça
[Musique]
j'ai rigolé j'étais un peu perturbé
pendant le numéro j'ai un message très
personnel à faire passer qui a laissé
son ipad sur mes affaires à l'équipe
technique
personnes diablo
garé à bon ben il ya un ipod café du
frisbee en fait quand j'ai pris le bruit
voilà
je suis désolé je suis très perturbé
j'ai envie de voir l'état du truc celle
qui je sais qu'il ya la moitié du public
qui se dit moss est prévu dans le
spectacle pas du tout
c'est jacky
c'est à toi charles hausser mon
régisseur vidéo qui fait sa dernière
avec nous ce soir du coup
je le pose là il a presque rien à partir
de ce moment précis du spectacle à
chaque fois que je croise le regard de
quelqu'un
là vous vous dites il vraiment perdu
avec sa chaise
dégagez vous à la main régime méga moi
vous m'avez pas fait les marques pour la
chaise du coup je sais pas où je la m
alors prenons notre temps et que du
spectacle ici ça fera diablo et bien
c'est parfait
c'est qui qui doit faire les marquages
non mais à la base
hommes comme un homme ça me va très bien
le mot sommes ok un ténor d'acolytes
remporté l'or dans quelques instants
[Musique]
alors premiers pas de la soirée
c'est parce que ça veut dire un pain un
pas dans le spectacle vivant c'est quand
il ya un régisseur qui fait un truc qui
devrait pas faire là vous avez entendu
de la musique il y en avait pas à cet
endroit là en temps normal
ces gars il c'est de la très jr
boulanger il fait des pins à chaque
spectacle comme ça la prochaine séquence
ckoi loïc la prochaine séquence c'est
l'imprévu que l'impreza l'un vous êtes
vu de la scène c'est un peu comme là
c'était un prévu après du coup c'est
l'imprévu sera bien tranquille pas le 2
prévu pas de blague étrangères mais je
voulais faire un truc imprévu genre
j'aurais pu le prévoir ça vraiment à
force d'être connaît déjà pu le prévoir
merci de
me donner des décimales pratique de
talent une course à bon en vrai du coup
tu as raison quand j'ai commencé à me
plonger à l'intérieur de py g tu vas
faire pipi ou caca mais
tu vas perdre 10 1 non mais c'est fini
ou oui d'accord bon t'as ton possible
moi ça m'arrive
j'ai voulu faire des trucs vraiment ce
spectacle et open
c'est bon il est parti j'ai envie de
compass un truc tout à l'heure alors je
m'appelle pas olivier fabien donc tu as
perdu déjà tu peux pas la pause et du
coup je suis désolé
ça fait pas attendre je me bats pour
qu'on m'appelle par mon prénom fabien
ben c'est pas une foire aux questions se
verra après si tu me posais une question
d'accords debout vraiment du coup tu
poses la question via
ramenez-moi des caisses de respect je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure j'en ai pas
trouvés là j'en trouve pas là bas
pourquoi lamayuru bas parce que j'en
mange mon pouce et tous ceux qui me
suivent le soc moi aussi pourquoi la
mayo dans le fond
j'vais pas faire la fin sur les jeux
on peut faire des impros comme ça tu
l'on tient on va faire une impôts il est
toujours là bas qui vient avec lee fait
coucou
c'est tip
top top arrêté avant qu'il revienne à un
moment donné dans le spectacle je vous
dirais le mot 10 - fruits le mot pomme
quand je dirais le mot pomme je ferai
une blague très nul et vous vous ferez
genre une standing-ovation vous rigolez
comme jamais et moi je dirais à eau vous
avez l'art fc sorti hier
si je le vois tu lui dis rien thibault
si je le vois applaudir et se marrer je
dirais tu sais pourquoi tu ris
pour voir s'il dit oui ou non
louis
ok oui moi ces bombes sont partis la
mise à
j'ai pas envie de finir ce spectacle on
passe trop bons moments comme ça
qu'est-ce qu'on s'emmerde à faire des
shows est tout de même plus où j'en suis
pour dire la vérité
mon dieu mon dieu mon bon faut que je
reprenne
et puis vous savez il ya un truc pour
dit chez moi c'est que si tu soucoupe ya
le pommier tu recevras toujours une
pomme
[Applaudissements]
asseyez-vous je savais pas si vous dire
si vous auriez l'aref ou pas
c'est quoi ton prénom genom toits en
blanc
loïc luc je t avais la rêve de ça tout
aussi du coup pourquoi tu applaudis
c'est dû siffler
devra pris dans le feu de l'action quoi
s'il votait la réf
elle est sortie hier on est d'accord
mais voilà
un tir
oh la
la prochaine séquence bajeux l'adorent
voulait peut-être vu en teasing au tout
début de cette vidéo je reçois temps en
temps des mecs de personnes qui me
disait ah c'est l'anniversaire de machin
ci peut le faire monter je ne réponds
pas ça parce que je veux pas trafiqué le
spectacle mais j'ai une demande pour
maromme particulière d'un gars qui
voulait demander quelque chose à sa
future femme j'aurais pas un peu spoil à
ce qui s'est passé et j'ai répondu parce
que il m'a touché et parce que c'était
la fin de la tournée voilà ce que ça a
rendu personne n'était au courant même
les régisseurs il y avait personne au
courant de la semaine même pas fait
il ne reste plus qu'une personne je
crois c'est florian oui florian on a
passé un petit peu de temps surtout on
va faire du cul berland 10 mhz d'accord
et oui je veux bien savoir ce que ces
avancées le double est alors le qr lundi
c'est un peu comme une prise de pouls
améliorée en gros c'est pas le coût mais
il ya aussi tous les tendons et le cul
berlin 10 mhz c'est une technique qui se
prévaut de savoir détecter des
micromouvements musculaire et surtout de
savoir en déduire quelque chose les
micro mouvements musculaires qui sont
incontrôlées et incontrôlables
donc on va essayer sur toi ça ok du coup
j'ai besoin que tu me rejoindre sur
scène parce que j'ai pas le bras assez
long des droitiers ou gauchers et
droitiers pourquoi
tu es droitier depuis toujours c'est ce
qu'on appelle un gaucher contrarié
hockey est ce que tu as envie dext du
cnes est mort d'un homme aussi mais toi
s'il te plaît tu m'as dit florian ok tu
vas te mettre face au public s'il te
plaît et tu vas t'en le bras droit comme
ceci remonte un tout petit peu la manche
parfait est ce que ça te dérange si je
te touche non ok donc je te prends je
dis petit prise de poids mais duraient
tout à la sauce galère sur une très
mauvaise nouvelle attendait
il est vivant c'est bon je dise qu'il
faut donc il faut que ton bras soit bien
relâché dire que quand moi je lâche tomb
raider tomber mais en même temps
c'était pas le cas dit voilà c'est
parfait ok tu penses à ta carte tu ne
cherches pas donné d'indicés d'accord il
faut que je te calibre c'est le premier
coup au départ on comptait un petit
calibrage carte qui peut être rouge noir
rouge ou noir rouge noir jeu très
perturbé par ce doigt là du coup je
dirais que c'est une carte rouge c'est
correct ou noir laisse moi finir mes
phrases qu'on s'en sortira jamais
rouge noir un talent se doit qui
tressautent hockey
bizarre
vic trêve coeur car au bik trêve coeur
car au bik trêve car carreaux
rouges noirs c'est une carte noire un tu
m'as dit ouais ça varie pas du tout tu
penses à ta carte en même temps ah bah
non je pensais à ma liste de courses du
pq les gorges est
vite trèfle pic trèfle as de trois as 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 valait d'amour à as ok
je tente un truc on va bien voir sortir
la carte que je pense que tu as choisie
je pense que c'est une carte à pic
non
je vais toujours me dire à quel car tu
pensais exactement
j'ai eu chaud là terme de pays coq est
très compliqué excellent bluffeur
excellent sang froid n'était pas si
c'est le cas c'est qu'ils te fais des
pulsations à la seconde mais c'est un
délire attend que je retourne pas ta
place je veux voir un truc sur ton
annulaire c'est très bizarre je vais
essayer avec l'autre main en fait ok au
timbre assez mais il est tatoué
fait à l'égard de la wii les amoureux
alors
ça c'est bizarre
comment s'appelle la personne qui est
venue avec toi hélène tu peux venir deux
secondes toits qu'il connaît j'aimerais
que tu prennes l'autre poignant même
temps que tu essayes de ressentir ce que
je voulais ressentir c'est juste au
niveau de cette année vers la prob du
coup il en a deux donc c'est pratique
mais
je te confie ça parle un peu dedans pour
voir les sept ressentir quelque chose en
même temps mais par lui à elle comme si
j'étais pas là
tu me sens bien
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai fait un peu perdre de temps à
fabien olicard
s'est passé quelque chose pendant nos
vacances il ya quelque chose qui s'est
pas fait
quelque chose
j'arrive tu veux un coup de main
de type a demandé un mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle a dû way
[Applaudissements]
en temps normal on dit on garde le
meilleur pour la fin la on a gardé le
pire pour la fin le pirate et richie six
arrivées durant ce spectacle sur cette
fin de tournée bah vous l'avez
maintenant
vous pouvez appeler hier très fort dès
le deuxième média vos espoirs c'est le
patio brieuc
n'est alors pas c'est plus fort que moi
avec david a transmis un truc à brieuc
qui l'a fait se lever quoi hockey brieuc
je récupère des cartes bonne soirée
non je parle aux messieurs il va où mais
il va ou ce qu il va chercher à boire et
n'hésitez-pas 1 1 non non non et
franchement vu ta life
pas de problème il à la retraite oui bon
il bosse il à la retraite il fait quoi
dans la vie
un atout faire quand je vais le faire
chier sur ces chantiers
est en train de pas comprendre pourquoi
le bar est fermé bas parce que c'est
vraiment pas la foire mon pote c'est un
spectacle tu sais
je cherchais du respect non j'en ai plus
ah
ah ben ouais ouais mais puisque moi je
t'avais a demandé moi on dirait pas mais
c'est mon boulot ce que je fais tous mes
yeux c'est toi
[Musique]
un
nom mais tout en mode pop ainsi à toi
crazy on t'attend moi j'ai tout mon
temps j'ai pas de baby sitter à avrillé
c'est la 2 3 qui s'en vient à moi oui
c'est fanny j'essaie de trouver ta date
de naissance dedans par contre elle me
sens pas tout on devrait lui le bar
elle serait
[Applaudissements]
je vois rigoler mais vous savez pas vous
ne savez pas que je le vis dormir 30
minutes john encore
c'est quoi ton prénom avec la gentille
jolie quitté avec toi qui te parle des
fois
la descente appelle un taxi jaune
e aurélie stéphanie moi mais là beaucoup
demandèrent va pirater olivier 1 je
pensais tout en s'en est passé des
choses c'est ce corner loïc à ça je me
souviens tous ces bons moments est ce
qu'on parle de la phrase que j'ai lu le
plus en dédicace cette année
je n'ai pas la logique non comment ça se
fait que t'es pas là présent est ce
qu'on peut leur dire peut-être qu'en
fait tu m'invites jamais ça s'effondre
mais non c'est faux c'est la fin d'année
c'est la fin d'année c'est la fin de
singularité ce spectacle est terminé
c'était trois ans de pur bonheur et je
repars l'oit en création d'un nouveau
spectacle dans une tournée qui s'appelle
singularité
ça s'appelle en création et je vais
faire cinquante neuf représentations où
je construis le spectacle dans des
petites salles intimes avec voûté entre
50 et 200 places en général vous avez la
liste de la tournée qui apparaît la ccc
très dense du coup comme c'est des
petites salles ça se remplit très vite
vous voulez venir je n'ai gardé pas trop
de trous quand même direct le lien y
sera ou en descriptions le mot de la fin
août la fin c'est entre toi et
merci à tous d'avoir c'est quand cette
vidéo merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo avec tous les passages de fabien
olicard ça donne vraiment envie d'aller
le voir aller le voir si vous n'allez
pas le voir je vous retrouve et je vous
en prie vous oblige à les voir n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner ça fait plaisir c'est
gratuit tu connais il s'appelle toujours
olivier sauciflard n'hésitez pas à bien
le nommé commissaire général merci à
tous à très bientôt pour la semaine
prochaine ciao c'est bizarre mais ça
marche